[Music]
on this tuesday night the staggering
destructions from bc's extreme weather
i've seen floods in this town but not
from rain and not this time of year
thousands homeless communities submerged
roads in ruins and a global news
photographer's traumatic close call this
roar came and it hit my truck
there was trees flying i thought it was
a goner
the conflict brewing within the federal
conservative party the infighting over
aaron o'toole's leadership and who's
leaping to his defense
and anger erupts over moscow's missile
test in space is this how russia has to
get people's attention the fears of what
the kremlin is up to
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with a devastating
impact of the extreme weather in bc
thousands of people are out of their
homes highways are completely washed
away and tonight there are reports
multiple people may have been killed
swept away in mudslides eyewitnesses had
told police they saw people in vehicles
caught in this a wall of mud and trees
cascading down the mountain and across
highway 99 north of pemberton b.c search
and rescue teams are still on the scene
and the rcmp confirmed a woman's body
has been recovered
the scale of the flooding is
unprecedented this is abbotsford nbc's
fraser valley the trans-canada highway
completely submerged and the water is
still rising this morning 1100 people
there were told to leave their homes
merit a city of 7 000 is still under
water a month's worth of rain fell in
two days
in the town of princeton flood waters
broke through a natural gas line cutting
off heat to hundreds of homes and
temperatures are set to plunge below
freezing this is what's left of the
trans-canada highway and the rail line
through the fraser canyon and this is
the coquihalla highway a big section
completely severed provincial officials
say the highways could take weeks if not
months to repair
we have extensive coverage tonight
beginning with robin gill and that
deadly mudslide
the intense rain had loosened so much
debris that it had nowhere to go but
across the highway north of whistler
global news photographer mike timbrell
was coming around to bend when the
mudslide hit i heard this loud
terrifying roar
sorry
it's okay
this roar came and it hit my truck
and there was trees flying
i had my seatbelt on
i took it off and i laid on the floor in
my truck
and my truck was moving all over getting
hammered by trees
i thought it was a goner before it all
came crashing down he had seen other
cars stopped and people standing on the
road now he's not sure they survived it
was almost like in the blink of an eye
there was a road
there's cars there's people
and then bang
everything was gone
search and rescue teams have confirmed
at least one body is buried in the
debris our teams did discover
a small number of vehicles on the slide
path on another highway east of
vancouver a rescue mission needed help
from the canadian military
this was monday when more than 200
people were airlifted out after spending
24 hours trapped in their cars caught
between two mudslides we kept our cars
running almost all night to stay warm
they're still not any closer to their
own beds it's another night at the local
high school or church and the
frustration is setting in you know we're
trapped here there's no help the heavy
rains have taken out parts of highway
one the main route of the trans-canada
highway in bc and part of the coquihalla
the major artery connecting vancouver to
the interior of the province in some
cases it could be hours or just a day or
two to remove debris in others such as
the the washout on the coquihalla it may
well be
you know several weeks or months in
abbotsford the farming community has now
expanded its evacuation order to more
than 1100 homes we are focused laser
focused on safe people's safety first i
am turning my mind already to livestock
and the poultry industry because we are
an ag producing jurisdiction number one
in canada
and there are still rescues happening
for people who tried to drive through
the deluge 5 000 cars were trapped at
one point in this community you could
not see where the side of the road was
people were going off the side of the
road we had cars flipped over as for
mike timbrell he was picked up by
another driver
but he won't ever forget what almost
happened to him
a matter of inches
me making it out
just inches
the shock of what's happening is still
palpable and he can't help thinking
about the others caught in the chaos
robin gill global news vancouver
there have been some terrifying moments
here's a little more from global news
photographer mike timbrell who was
driving back from his cabin yesterday on
highway 99. he thought he'd made it
through the worst of it when he came
upon some cars and people stopped on the
road
the people started walking back
towards their vehicles and they were
like on both sides of the road
and as that happened i heard this loud
terrifying roar
sorry
this roar came and it hit my truck
and there was trees flying
i had my seatbelt on
i took it off and i laid on the floor in
my truck
and my truck was moving all over getting
hammered by trees
i thought it was a goner
it finally all stopped
and
i managed to get out the passenger door
and run
i i turned around looked to my truck
it was half buried
and all the cars that were on the road
all the people
they were just gone
gone
global news photographer mike timbrell
the city of merit bc remains off limits
an evacuation order issued yesterday is
expected to stay in place for at least a
week water levels are dropping but
officials have yet to assess the damage
to the city's wastewater treatment plant
and other vital infrastructure some
residents are watching it all unfold
from afar including the owner of this
home whose doorbell camera captured the
flood water
rising up to the porch
with so many highways washed out there
aren't too many places to go some people
are sheltering in kamloops that's where
our heather urex west is tonight heather
some evacuees though may be on the move
again
yeah donna it has just been an
exhausting ordeal for the people of
merit all day people have been lining up
outside this evacuation reception center
here in kamloops but the city does not
have enough accommodation for everyone
class number one the evacuees of merit
on the move for a second time
to kelowna because it's the only place
they found accommodations for us david
stringer had to be rescued by boat after
flood water surrounded his merit trailer
on monday he spent a long night on a cot
here in kamloops before hitting the road
again it's been pretty stressful we were
in merit bc and we got evacuated twice
yesterday first time we went to my
grandma's house then it started to flood
there jordan young found one of the last
rooms in town trying to turn the
harrowing ordeal into a fun adventure
for her two little girls there was a
flood yeah there's a flood and we saw it
the flooding took many in merit by
surprise after the city's water
treatment facility failed the city of 7
000 was placed under an evacuation order
luckily the amount of water that was
coming down the rivers is down
substantially
the waters are starting to recede
but that doesn't mean the city is safe
for residents to return the community is
still without water or sewage and parts
of the city can no longer be safely
accessed at all unfortunately overnight
the one of the spans of the middlesboro
bridge which is the central one of the
three bridges collapsed into the river
as a result we're not confident about
the structural integrity of any bridge
of the cold water river officials aren't
sure how many people have remained in
merit but those who have left aren't
being allowed back inside rcmp
barricades have been set up around the
community stressed
yeah just want to get back home and
and
just get the kids back to school they
miss school and everything
but there is little that can be done
just three months after nearly losing
their community to fires residents of
merit forced out by a devastating flood
and while the rains have stopped in
merit what could hamper cleanup efforts
now is the cold once the sun sets
tonight the temperature is expected to
drop to -8 which means that lingering
flood water there could turn to ice
donna all right heather urich's west
thanks
survivors of sexual misconduct in the
military are still waiting for a
long-promised and legally required
apology from the federal government the
deadline to submit claims for a
settlement as part of a class action
lawsuit is next week and the number of
claimants has now soared to more than 15
thousand there have been over 1400 new
claimants in just one week
our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stephenson reports
an apology is a validation two years
after survivors of military sexual
misconduct were promised an apology from
the government of canada and the
canadian armed forces they're still
waiting at this time last year survivors
were told the apology was imminent
but it never came and while it may be
just a gesture the acknowledgment of
what survivors have experienced is
important validation for many apologies
can be very powerful when they're
sincere
nine months into the military sexual
misconduct scandal that has rocked the
canadian armed forces the apology is
finally coming according to a senior
defense source and i'm sincerely sorry
but unlike other high-profile apologies
by the liberal government for historic
wrongs it will not be delivered by prime
minister justin trudeau or his defense
minister or any elected member of the
liberal government instead it will be
acting chief of the defense staff
general wayne eyre and deputy minister
jody thomas who will be on tap
that sends the wrong message according
to megan mckenzie an expert on military
culture i think the apology should come
from the prime minister a move mckenzie
says would signal the gravity of the
apology and commitment to change the
military culture which has been plagued
by allegations of sexual misconduct at
the top there's kind of an irony that
there's been
two different
chief of defense staffs that could have
delivered this apology but are now
embroiled in their own scandals and
allegations
the government is legally required to
apologize as part of a 900 million
dollar class action lawsuit settlement
that was reached in 2019. advocates say
the true sincerity of the government
will be measured in actions taken and
not just in the apologies delivered
mercedes stevenson global news ottawa
tensions are escalating at the fortified
border between poland and belarus polish
forces used water cannon and tear gas
against migrants who were throwing rocks
and trying to break through barbed wire
fences at least 18 people were injured
including seven police officers about
four thousand migrants mostly from the
middle east are stranded at the border
poland has deployed thousands of troops
to try to hold them back and the
president of belarus alexander
lukashenka is accused of pushing the
migrants to the border to try to
destabilize the eu in revenge for
sanctions on his authoritarian regime he
denies engineering the crisis and claims
his government has deported five
thousand illegal migrants
a drug maker makes a deal coming up
pfizer's prescription to help make
treatment for covid19 more accessible
the drug company moderna has asked
health canada to authorize its covid19
vaccine for children aged 6 to 11.
health canada says it will make the
review a priority it will include an
assessment of clinical trial data to be
sure the benefits outweigh the risks
this is the second covid19 vaccine
awaiting authorization for kids under 12
in canada health canada received a
submission from pfizer last month and
expects to issue a decision in the next
two weeks
pfizer has struck a deal to let generic
drug companies produce its experimental
covid19 antiviral pill the agreement
covers 95 lower income countries and
could make the treatment available to
more than half the world's population
the antiviral pill is urgently needed in
places struggling with access to
vaccines crystal commansing explains
nearly two years into the pandemic a new
deal that could help treat covet 19.
pfizer says it will allow lower income
countries to make and sell its
experimental antiviral pill potentially
doesn't have to be that expensive to
produce
and doesn't require people to go to
hospital the deal allows established
generic drug manufacturers to apply to
make the pills royalty free a similar
agreement was also signed with merck
pfizer's antiviral pill is designed to
stop the virus from replicating the
company shared promising clinical trial
data earlier this month within three
days of the symptoms you have now 89
protection from disease
leading to hospitalization with our
medicines the new deal applies to 95
countries covering about 53 percent of
the world's population doctors without
borders asks what about the other 47
percent
as a matter of humanity we cannot let
this exhibited
profitary
behavior
delay the course of ending this pandemic
the pandemic has revealed deep health
inequities experts say the focus must be
on boosting access to covet 19 vaccines
it's not fair that you know as canadians
we're getting ready for a booster shot
when there are so many countries who've
yet to administer the first shot
particularly to vulnerable communities
like healthcare workers
with more than a quarter of a billion
infections and counting the fight
against the virus is far from over
crystal gomanson global news london
conservative party push back ahead the
clash over aaron o'toole's leadership
the leader of the federal conservative
party is pushing back on those in the
party who question his leadership erin
o'toole has now kicked senator denise
batters out of the conservative national
caucus in a statement o'toole says i
will not tolerate an individual
discrediting and showing a clear lack of
respect towards the efforts of the
entire conservative caucus batters has
launched a petition calling for an
immediate review of o'toole's leadership
but more than 25 conservative mps and
the party president are defending him
our chief political correspondent david
aiken is keeping an eye on this for us
david
well donna when the knives came out for
andrew scheer after the 2019 election
few and caucus stood up for him it is
different this time plenty of people in
aaron o'toole's caucus about one quarter
of all conservative mps in fact are
publicly defending their leader i'm
happy to be part of
erin o'toole's team mp melissa lantzman
says she is a hard no to what her caucus
colleague senator denise batters is
trying to do came here and i was sent
here by the voters in thornhill to stand
up for canadians and all of this is the
infighting is a distraction and i'm
launching a petition so more than two
dozen conservatives took to social media
to say the same thing deputy leader
candice bergen declared her full support
for o'toole harper-era cabinet minister
ed fast tweeted at senator batters by
name saying he can't fathom why she
wants to focus on leadership games
rather than on issues that matter to
canadians and the party president rob
batherson jumped in saying batter's
petition was out of order that support
for o'toole from the party brass is also
something sheer never had david aiken
global news ottawa
canadian blood services wants to end the
ban on donations from gay and bisexual
men the agency will ask health canada to
focus donation screening on sexual
behavior to determine the risk of
transmission of hiv and not on a donor's
gender or sexuality right now a man who
has had sex with a man in the last three
months cannot donate blood a straight
man regardless of their number of
partners in the same time frame can
donate
once canadian blood services submits its
application to change the screening
requirements it will be up to health
canada to approve it and the process
could take several months to a year
cosmic carelessness next russia's
reckless move that endangered astronauts
[Music]
there's a big match in edmonton tonight
canada's men's soccer team is taking on
top ranked mexico in a world cup
qualifier weather could be a factor
temperatures are forecast to drop which
could be a bit of a shock for the
mexican team
minus 10 is not easy on anybody so
that's going to be a little bit tough
but uh i mean you know we're canadian
we're built for the good for this
weather
beating mexico tonight could move canada
one step closer to securing a spot in
the 2022 world cup
one country getting a yellow card by the
international community over its
recklessness in outer space is russia on
monday it launched a missile to destroy
one of its old satellites in orbit and
as eric sorensen reports it's being
called an irresponsible act that
triggered a dangerous chain reaction
this month russia released military
video of its new missile systems capable
of intercepting other missiles aircraft
and satellites what few expected was
this that russia would shoot down one of
its own defunct satellites dispersing an
estimated 1500 pieces of shrapnel into
orbit threatening some of the 3 400
active satellites above earth the
largest is the international space
station the crew of four americans two
russians and a german were forced to
take shelter in their docked space
capsules for two hours in the event they
had to leave suddenly washington is
furious russia's dangerous and
irresponsible behavior jeopardizes the
long-term sustainability of outer space
and clearly demonstrates that russia's
claims of opposing the weapons
weaponization of space are disingenuous
and hypocritical russia insists the
fragments pose no risk and calls the u.s
criticism hypocritical
foreign minister sergey lavrov says
russia is prepared to negotiate rules
for space and says it's the americans
who are creating an arms race
around 30 000 space objects anything
larger than an iphone are being tracked
with countless smaller pieces speeding
around earth
the film gravity dramatized a spacecraft
being destroyed by debris from a russian
satellite explosion
in real life the space station's
canadarm was pierced by debris this year
no serious damage but proof that the
risk is not science fiction space
watchers are mystified by russia's
actions this was an explosive event that
created debris that affects not just the
space station but many other nation
satellites and really is this how russia
has to get people's attention satellites
are essential for communications weather
forecasting and financial and global
security nato is concerned russia wants
geopolitical leverage in space to
demonstrate that russia is now
developing new weapon systems that can
shoot down satellites washington says it
will work with allies to develop a
response meantime the u.s russia and
china are all building arsenals of
anti-satellite weapons eric sorensen
global news toronto
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight here
in canada is the town of brigas
newfoundland and labrador we'd love to
see your canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
you